6-minute English from the BBC
Hello, this is 6-minute English from BBC Learning English, I'm Neil
And I'm Beth
Have you ever been sent a text reminding you about a doctor's appointment
or impulsively bought something on the internet because there was only one left?
If any of these have happened to you, then you've been nudged
A Nudge is a subtle way of altering human behaviour
It's a powerful way for governments, advertisers and social media companies to encourage
or nudge people into making choices that benefit themselves and society as a whole
Imagine the government want people to eat better
It might encourage supermarkets to put healthy snacks in easy to reach shelves
near the checkout and hide the chocolate bars out of sight on the top shelf
Shoppers are being nudged to eat better
Well, that's the idea anyway
But often nudging is used less to benefit society and more to make money for big business
And it happens more often than people realise
So in this programme, we'll be asking whether the idea behind nudging
to influence human behaviour for good is still true today
And as usual, we'll be learning some useful new vocabulary as well
But first I have a question for you, Beth
Another example of nudging happened in Woolwich, an area of London which in 2011
had a problem with anti-social behaviour and particularly with shop windows being smashed
The local authority decided to use nudging to fix the problem
by painting pictures on the shop windows
But what did they paint?
Was it A cute kittens, B, babies faces or C, barking dogs
I guess barking dogs would keep the window breakers away
Okay, Beth, I'll reveal the correct answer later in the programme
Nudging started in 2008 with the publication of a book by Nobel Prize-winning economist Professor Richard Taylor
Professor Taylor's ideas about how to gently persuade people into making good decisions
became known as Nudge Theory
Advertising executive Rory Sutherland introduced Nudge Theory to his agency Ogilvy
Here's Rory explaining more to BBC Radio 4 programme analysis
Let's say you make the profitable option button green and highly attractive
The less profitable option you make it kind of grey and kind of manky looking
Okay, that would be an example of something which is
You know, a nudge not necessarily used in the best interests of the consumer
Advertisers use colours to nudge customers towards the profitable option
The one which is the most likely to make money
These appear brightly coloured and attractive on the screen
Whereas less profitable options are made to look manky
A slang word meaning dirty and unattractive
Here nudging isn't being used for the public good
These dark nudges, also called sludge, make money for a company
But are not always in the best interests of the consumer
If something is in your best interests, it's the most advantageous and beneficial thing for you to do
Dark nudges have caused many to question the morality of nudging
Including Neil Levy, Professor of Ethics at Oxford University
Speaking here to BBC Radio 4 programme analysis
The big one, the one people have concentrated on
Is that it's paternalistic
That is that nudge might be in our interests
But we want to make our own decisions
That's for people worry that nudges
Infantilise us
It's undermining our autonomy
Critics of nudging call it paternalistic
Meaning it wants to make decisions for people
Rather than letting them take responsibility for themselves
They also claim nudging infantilises people
It treats them like children
And as a result, people lose autonomy
The ability to make your own decisions about what to do
Rather than being told by someone else
I guess nudging itself is neither good nor bad
It just depends how you use it
Well, let's look on the positive side by revealing the answer to your question, Neil
Right, I asked you how authorities in Woolwich in South East London
Nudged anti-social window breakers to behave nicely
I guess it was by painting pictures of scary barking dogs on the windows
Which was the wrong answer I'm afraid Beth
In fact, Woolwich Council hired graffiti artists to paint pictures of local babies faces onto the window shutters
Not even the most hard-hearted criminal smashed those windows
And anti-social behaviour fell by 18% in one year
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned in this programme about nudging
Ways of gently persuading or encouraging someone to take decisions
Something which is profitable makes a profit or is likely to make money
Manky is slang for dirty and unattractive
If something is in your best interests
It's the most advantageous beneficial thing for you to do
A paternalistic person prefers making decisions for other people
Rather than letting them take responsibility for their own lives
To infantilise someone means to treat them as if they were a child
And finally, autonomy is the ability to make your own decisions about what to do
Rather than being told by someone else
Once again, our six minutes are up
Remember to join us again next time for more topical discussion
And useful vocabulary here at six minute English
Goodbye for now
Goodbye
Six minute English from the BBC